[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Anthony Graham and it's my
privilege to serve on the SI farts Board
of Directors as my absolute pleasure to
welcome all of you here this evening in
particular I would like to welcome and
recognize her honor
the Honorable Elizabeth Dodds well the
leftenant governor of Ontario who were
delighted to join us is unique and while
you are all special guests in our minds
there's two in particular that I'd like
to make special welcome and a
recognition of this evening
the Honorable Kirsty Duncan Canada's
Minister of science and the Honourable
resi more Eadie
Ontario's minister of research
innovation science
we are truly honored to have both of you
here tonight and at a time when science
and the role of science is increasingly
important yet increasingly marginalized
were honored as a province and as a
nation to have ministers of science who
are in fact scientists and are able to
bring their scientific expertise to
their portfolios so welcome later this
evening we'll be hearing from three of
our new CFR as a rally global scholars
these are extraordinary researchers who
are early in their careers but who have
already achieved important distinctions
for me
these young researchers exemplify what
is great about CFR their work on an
artificial intelligence next-generation
energy and the interplay of economics
and culture tackles vitally important
issues that require sustained
interactions with eye diverse network of
distinguished peers that's the advantage
that CFR provides to our fellows and to
today we need that advantage that c4
advantage more than ever before the
world faces complex problems that can't
be resolved by any one researcher or any
one country
climate change child welfare and the
genetics of disease these are all
problems that require a global and
interdisciplinary approach that's what
see far has been providing for over 35
years
CFR's global research networks connect
the world's best minds across
disciplines to tackle research questions
our profound importance to humanity it's
an effort that I am proud to be part of
I thank all of you for being part of it
too
so now it's my great pleasure to welcome
our president CEO dr. Ellen Burstyn Alan
thank you very much Tony I'd also like
to extend a welcome to the Honorable
Elizabeth Doswell leftenant governor of
Ontario
although the leftenant governor doesn't
have a speaking role or maybe because
she doesn't I think it's a measure of
her sincere and deep interest in science
that she's actually coming to this is
probably your third or fourth event at
sea far to actually hear science so it's
it's great to have you here your honor
thank you very much for being here
I also like Tony would like to welcome
the Honorable Christy Duncan minister of
science for Canada and the honourable
reason really
Ontario's minister of science research
and innovation or research science and
innovation thank you both to both of you
for being here you know those of us who
are scientists I think feel we have a
privileged life because Society is
actually paying us to do what we like to
do I'd love to do actually and so I
think it's a special person who would
choose to leave science and enter the
political arena and I think every
Canadian both in this province and
across the country is so grateful to to
both ministers of science who are here
with us tonight
who have given up a sort of a blessed
life in science to enter that other
world so thank you both very much on
behalf of everybody
I'd also like to recognize many members
of CFR's
a great truly great Board of Directors
who are here with us tonight our chair
Barb's Tommy it's straight ahead of me
Tony Graham have you already heard from
Lindsay Gordon Jill willette Pat
Meredith Lawrence Peyton Brenda Eaton
and these are colleagues and board
members from across across the country
you do truly tremendous work for CFR our
board meeting earlier today I think was
a great example of the wisdom and the
dedication and commitment to see far
that that we are also privileged to be
able to take advantage of I also want to
recognize CFR's honorable fellow
Richard Ivey sitting straight ahead of
me here richard has been on the board of
directors sat on the board of directors
for at least 20 years and served as the
chair for a number of years and Richard
I think no one has more dedicated than
you to this organization than Richard
Ivey thank you very much Richard for
being here
well we all know Canada's 150 this year
so we pale in comparison we're 35 we
being not me but see far I think it's
really like any sort of birthday it's a
good time to look back and to look
forward and I think see far certainly
has many things to be proud of over its
35-year history the Canada arm many
people don't know this i think george
fear heller one of the founding members
of the board of directors of CFR will
know this the Canada arm had its origins
at ciar it was called in those days our
deep understanding of child development
and well-being again goes back to the
1980s and continues to this very day
indeed our program in child and brain
development is meeting as we speak out
in Vancouver spectacular advances in
artificial intelligence if you read
about it you'll read about deep learning
and AI and it's not an understatement to
say that it all had its origins in
Canada and in C far and you'll hear from
one of its younger protagonists in a few
moments
and they're all being led by fellows in
our program and learning and machines
and brains I told the board today the
the godfathers of deep learning as it's
called our Joshua been CEO for the
University of Montreal young Laocoon
from the University from New York
University and now Facebook and geoff
hinton from the university of toronto
there's a company in in england that
will sell you a t-shirt so I bought it I
forgot to bring it tonight all it has on
it is yahshua Jeff and yon there's no
need to say any more
it's quite remarkable actually I'm
equally excited of course that we'll see
far as future I think the the challenges
that the world faces the scientific
opportunities that are now at our
fingertips
have never been greater than they are
today it's a wonderful time I think to
be a scientist and to be the president
of C far shortly after I started we
launched C far 2.0 it builds on our
strengths and really catalyzing
disruptive research we are not in the
business of incremental advances we're
kind of the risk capitalists of science
we go for bold complex tough but
important questions and the way we
mitigate that risk is we bring together
the very very best minds in the planet
that we can to come together to address
the problem and I think that's been our
sort of secret sauce for the last 35
years and will certainly continue to be
for the next 35 one of the key
priorities that we recognized under 2.0
who was the next generation of research
leaders and you will hear from three
outstanding young people in a moment
they are among the very first cohort of
18 scholars from five countries that we
appointed as the first see far as
reality global scholars and the
motivation for that program was simple
young people are the future they bring
the intelligence the enthusiasm non
naivete the plasticity neuronal
plasticity that you require to be a
great scientist and they're fearless
at the same time it's never been harder
to be a young scientist today funding is
tight demands on your time and on your
intellect are coming at you every which
way you're learning how to mentor your
first graduate students how to change
your first diaper pay your first
mortgage payment teach your first course
write your first grant it's hard so the
the as really global Scholars Program
was really designed to give a kickstart
to people who we think at least are
outstanding and show outstanding promise
we're very fortunate that the as really
foundation decided that they agreed that
this was an important thing to do and
have become with us as partners and
visionary donors recognising the
importance of young people and I know
that the only s really is us here with
their this evening and her and her
foundation have really been just
tremendous partners and friends to work
with so no it's great to see you
[Applause]
that that program against at least three
or four things to young people first
they become attached to the program that
most fits their own scientific interests
and so like the MasterCard ad says
that's priceless because they get to
interact with the world's top 20 or 30
scientists in their own field on a
regular basis for two or three years
second they get mentored by a senior
individual in the field not necessarily
from their own country even but someone
who has a clear interest in mentoring
them third they get money they got a
hundred thousand dollars of unrestricted
research money for the two years they're
at as really global scholar and fourth
we're putting together a leadership
experience where these young emerging
research leaders will be exposed to each
other whether they're physicists and
economists the mathematician a
geneticist what-have-you and they'll be
exposed to leadership leaders in society
who will talked with them about what
does it mean to be a leader not
necessarily in science or research but
across society so we're very excited
about this program I think the people
we've identified so far are just
incredible and I'm looking forward to
seeing what happens with this and of
course see far fellows all close to 400
from 18 countries continue to
demonstrate the very highest level of
excellence that one can possibly imagine
we have over the last year our fellows
have collected about 70 of the world's
highest awards and highest I mean
highest art McDonald who the great
Canadian physicist who won the Nobel
Prize last year and in October is a CFR
fellow and and on it goes
on monday the erasmus prize which is a
major prize given by the king of the
netherlands will be announced and it
will be going to a CFR fellow and a
social scientist i'm not supposed to
tell you who it is because it hasn't
been announced yet but it's a very
prestigious award in the social sciences
probably the major award in the social
sciences and the cavity prize etc the
Nobel the CAV Lee there
Smith's BBVA prize went to geoff hinton
for artificial intelligence and on it
goes I've said this to my wife with if
we were a university and I apologized to
representatives and various universities
who are know are here who I know are
here we would be by far the best
university on the planet so my wife said
well yeah you cherry-pick so of course
you're the best
but Harvard cherry-picks an MIT
cherry-picks and you have t cherry-picks
but see if our cherry picks the best
just one example actually I think
there's been about seven companions of
the Order of Canada announced in the
last two years the companion of course
as many of you know is the very highest
honor that our nation can bestow on a
civilian it's a member of the officer
it's a member of the Order of Canada the
highest order for of that 7rc for
fellows Brenda Andrews janitress aunt
Vicki Caspi and art McDonald it's quite
a remarkable statistic and actually none
of us as far as I know had anything to
do with that other than this for great
scientists who have been honored in such
a deep way our 14 programs continue to
make huge progress I'm not going to go
into any detail on that but I recommend
you look at our website that if you have
any questions please come and see me or
anybody on our staff to ask them about
it finally I'd like to mention a very
exciting project for CFR we're going to
Mars
March to the six is our moving date we
move out March the third we move in
March to the six we're very excited
about that it's the new headquarters we
will be surrounded by many colleagues
who are interested in research and
innovation I think it's a great move for
this organization and we're very all
very excited about it and we'll be there
we'll be having a pizza party if you
want to help us unpack on Monday March
the 6th you're all invited
it's all so finally I want to thank
everybody in this room for your support
for c4 we appreciate it very much it's
essential to do the work that we do we
think we use your support very wisely
and picking the very best people and
choosing the very best problems with
complex and important problems that we
can find right now we'd like to
introduce our next speaker minister
Kirsty Duncan as Tony mentioned earlier
we are very lucky to have two ministers
of science who are both scientists they
understand the culture of science the
importance of science the pace of
science the the challenges of being a
scientist I think that empathy and that
understanding means so much to the
scientific community and it means so
much I think to this country and so
behalf of all of us at sea far thank you
Kirsty and and you mr. Maruti for taking
this on Minister Duncan
Canada's minister of science was an
associate professor of Health Studies at
the University of just I'm going to
continue at the University of Toronto
she was a former research director for
the AIC Institute of corporate
citizenship at the Rotman School of
Management she's a renowned
international speaker she represented
Canada on the international climate
change Commission
she's lectured for many organizations
including the National Geographic
Society the Government of Japan and the
young presidents organization she has a
PhD in geography from the University of
Edinburgh please join me in welcoming
Minister Duncan Canada
[Applause]
good evening everyone
and Alan thank you for your kind words
thank you for inviting me to this
prestigious event and I would like to
acknowledge your enormous contributions
to science your lifetime of service to
science into this country
[Applause]
I'd like to also to acknowledge that we
are on the traditional territory of
several indigenous nations and I'd like
to recognize the long history and
contributions of the First Nations matey
and Inuit in Ontario I'd like to extend
warm greetings to our distinguished
guests who join us tonight of course our
leftenant governor the Honorable
Elizabeth Doubt's well raise the
meridian Terios minister of research
innovation in science members of the as
reality family his foundation's generous
support for CFR helps many global
scholars and to everyone from the
scientific community here to our
distinguished guests thank you for
supporting CFR I don't have to tell you
for more than 30 years
CFR has brought together extraordinary
and I mean extraordinary researchers
from across Canada and around the world
to address questions of global
importance we are proud to support their
work and the broad international reach
of this organization again let me
express how grateful I am for the work
that's too far to all of you we value
science we respect scientists and the
important work you do each and every day
and we believe making decisions based on
evidence is a Canadian value and one
that we will continue to promote we also
want to as Alan mentioned it's hard for
young researchers right now and we want
young researchers to be able to have
nights like these
and to be able to have their research
dreams so which brings me the reason why
we're here tonight to recognize the
outstanding global scholars so I would
just like to take a minute or two to pay
tribute to three early career
researchers being supported by CFR and
the as really Foundation through the
global Scholars Program dr. Natalie Bao
was based at the University of Toronto's
she's the social scientist she's an
economist engaged in seafarers
institutions organizations and growth
research program and she's looking at
inequities among countries dr. Gabriela
Gabriela schlau Cohen who is a
researcher from MIT and who's arrived
tonight to be here and she's part of
CFR's bio-inspired solo energy program
and this program aims at understanding
the biological mechanisms used by plants
algae and photosynthetic bacteria to
harvest light and then apply those
strategies to improve solar power
technology and then we'll hear from dr.
Graham Taylor who's based at the
University of Guelph and as Allen has
said dr. Taylor is part of learning in
machines in the brain research program
all three of the people we will have the
privilege of listening to are remarkable
early career researchers and I think we
should all take a minute
[Applause]
to the three global scholars you inspire
us all on behalf of the Government of
Canada I want to thank you for your
commitment to science to serving the
public good congratulations on being
part of the inaugural cohort of the CFR
as reality global scholars we wish you
the best of luck and I know all of us
will be looking forward to learning
about your research to all of you
gathered thank you for the work you do
to see far thank you for bringing the
world together
merci congratulations
[Applause]
thank you very much Minister Duncan now
my pleasure and honor to introduce
Minister Moretti
the Honorable Minister Meridius
Ontario's Minister of research
innovation and science she was first
elected to the Ontario legislature in
2007 as the MPP for Richmond Hill and
has been reelected twice in 2011 and
2014 prior to his current role he was
minister of research and innovation as
well as the Minister for training
colleges and universities Minister
meridia is a graduate of Tehran
University in Iran and he earned his PhD
from Brunel University in London UK he's
elected a fellow of the Institute of
Physics and admitted as the fellow of
the institution of engineering and
technology of the United Kingdom prior
to entering into politics he had a
17-year career at the radiation Safety
Institute of Canada where he was the
vice president and chief scientist
please join me in welcoming Minister
Moretti
[Applause]
Thank You Alan for that very kind and
gracious introduction I must make a
little editorial that I am NOT anymore a
double minister I used to be double
minister Minister for research and
innovation and the Minister for training
college the universities but after the
cabinet shuffled in June I said to a
premier that you are paying me one
salary I am running to ministers
Minister of Labour will have objected
that so now I am only administered first
research innovation and they added the
word science to it as well so it's a
great pleasure ladies and gentlemen to
be here and your honor mr. Duncan ladies
and gentlemen I would like to begin by
thanking everyone at the Canadian
Institute for Advanced Research for the
outstanding work that you do every day
you have an impressive track record see
far supports researchers at over 130
institutions worldwide including 83
people from 11 organizations in our
province of Ontario and the 18 Nobel
Prize winners have received Savar
support including our own dr. Arthur
McDonald the 2015 Nobel Prize winner in
physics for showing that neutrinos those
little tiny particles that they have a
mass this was one of the questions I was
asked when I was doing one of my
master's degree in nuclear physics about
something called the beta decay this was
a very interesting scientific story that
people couldn't explain the beta decay
meaning that radioactive material as far
as a particle called beta particles but
this phenomena actually broke down two
major conservation laws of physics one
was conservation of energy and the other
one was conservation of mass and there
was a very imaginative scientist he said
there must be something there which we
don't see it it must be very little tiny
so they called it neutrino and nobody
knew what the students are until art he
basically showed that these neutrinos
they have really mass and by the way art
McDonald I mentioned him I said art you
have to bring another Nobel Prize for us
a one is not enough so he said he's
working on dark matter and hopefully if
you can get to something breakthrough we
will have another Nobel Prize in the
near future for our country Canada see
far brings together some of the world's
best research scientists and the minds
people who can spark groundbreaking
ideas and your groundbreaking work in
artificial intelligence as you already
hear his set in Canada has a global
global leader in that area I was at the
Northern California just last week and
the visiting University of California at
Berkeley and as many of you in this room
will know that there are two major
centers for artificial intelligence in
North America's one is of course
University of California at Berkeley and
the other one University of Toronto the
contribution sea far is making our
fasting Ontario's research and the
innovation ecosystem and of course you
are inspiring young leaders as well I
look forward to hearing from three of
these young leaders later this evening
as researchers we often face tough
challenges with serious implications for
example a child depends on you to help
their parents survive a deadly disease
like cancer and in Ontario as you know
we are one of the leaders in cancer
research Ontario Institute for cancer
research is one of the leaders in North
America at least people around the world
look for you for researchers to answer
to meet future energy needs and come
back the effects of global warming which
is we know it is real
and we know these challenges demand a
research and critical thinking
world-renowned physicist Stephen Hawking
who has a special relationship with our
Perimeter Institute for Theoretical
Physics and Waterloo
including a center there that is named
after him once said intelligence is the
ability to adapt to change so ladies and
gentlemen we need new ways of thinking
to address today's challenges we need
exceptional minds like yours working
together to make that transformative
discoveries and that's why government of
Ontario is proud to support the Canadian
Institute for Advanced Research our
investment supports global research
networks working on a number of
Ontario's priority areas including
artificial intelligence as you hit
quantum computing which is going to take
us to the next level in computer
engineering we will move from actually
we have moved from analog electronics to
digital electronics in 1945 1948 started
by the invention of transistor now we
have been in digital electronics and
will be moving towards towards computer
sorry quantum computing or quantum
electronics maybe in five to ten years I
have been told and indeed life sciences
sector as well so facilitating global
connections here in Ontario is vital for
research as well as for our provinces
future as we move very fast in building
our knowledge-based economy and that is
the way our country and our province can
compete around the world in terms of
economic growth we cannot rely on
traditional manufacturing
knowledge-based manufacturing advanced
manufacturing and knowledge-based
economy is the way to go and the engine
behind knowledge-based economy is
science scientific thinking scientific
work and
innovation these are the things which we
have great talents in our country and
our province collaboration ladies and
gentleman raises in our international
profile around the world and the most
importantly it leads to life-changing
breakthroughs that extend beyond our
borders and that's why Sephora has been
doing for a number of years since its
inception in 1982 for example to finding
new ways to make sure when a child turns
on tap clean drinking water flows now
researchers from the province of Ontario
and the China are working together to
solve that very problem for China the
south to north water diversion project
in China is helping accelerate the use
of Ontario based water treatment
technologies in that country and it is
helping to provide safe drinking water
for people of China including Beijing
the capital city we want to support more
great collaboration of this nature and
that's why we will continue to
strengthen our international
relationship to Fund agreements with
other countries including Germany Israel
India and of course China and other
countries our government also knows that
how important it is to help early career
researchers right here at home and
that's why we have awarded more than 900
early research awards over the last
decade including one to dr. Michael Tim
Ian scheme Michael is a neurosurgeon at
the University Health Network and he did
something researchers thought was
impossible he invented a drug that
limits brain damage from a stroke and
the drug could potentially be used to
treat people with Alzheimer's diseases
which could help a lot of family
right here in our province of Ontario
and our country Canada ladies and
gentlemen as you know Ontario has so
much to offer to the world a talented
workforce innovative companies and a
world-class innovation ecosystem we need
to tell our story to the world so we can
open up further opportunities for our
researchers and for our businesses and
ultimately create more good jobs here in
our province of Ontario I was as I said
in Silicon Valley and Northern
California's last week and I noticed
there that doing business in Silicon
Valley is becoming more and more
expensive and we have in Ontario
I mean Ottawa Toronto Waterloo Corridor
is equivalent to Silicon Valley in terms
of talents there are 250,000 Ontario
graduates in science and engineering are
working in Silicon Valley and that we do
have a Silicon Valley here and I think
now people are looking at Ontario to
bring their research companies here to
conduct research in Ontario and we need
to just to tell our stories and her
honor is doing her best in terms of
telling Ontario stories to the world and
they all need to follow her path so that
people around the world will know we are
here and that we have that talent in
Ontario so that we can we can succeed
and I think that is the way to go for
our province of Ontario and just in
closing I want to thank Alan yourself
and your colleagues and the board
members and the Institute as a whole for
the great work you do and the great
profile you bring to our country Canada
by the work you do internationally in
terms of bringing those the networking
and the connecting the top minds in the
world which as a result of their work
not only we benefit in Ontario and
Canada but seven billion human beings on
our bigger country called planet
we all benefit from the work the
scientists they do and the work you
facilitate which they can carry on so
thank you very much merci beaucoup young
global scholars I'm going to introduce
John Hepburn so we're going to have a
chain of cascade of introductions here
John Hepburn is C farce VP research he
assumed that position almost a year ago
last June after we conducted a very long
and exhaustive search I must say he's
already providing great and strong
leadership both within the organization
as an ambassador for the organization on
the outside and I feel especially lucky
to have a great colleague and John
Hepburn he comes to us from the
University of British Columbia where he
was the VP of research for a very long
time I think he survived three or four
university presidents they keep the same
one twice and before that he was the
professor in the department's of
chemistry physics and astronomy he's a
PhD in chemistry from the University of
Toronto completed his undergraduate
chemist chemistry degree at the
University of Waterloo and he has many
honors to his name just a couple he is a
Rutherford metal in physics from the
Royal Society of Canada elected
fellowships in the American Physical
Society and the chemical Institute of
Canada and an Alfred P sloan Foundation
fellowship it's one of the few people
who can say trained with two Nobel
laureates please join me in welcoming
John Hepburn
thank you very much Alan and good
evening everyone now for what you've all
been really waiting for as wonderful as
the food has been we're going to hear
from three of our first cohort of as
really global scholars and this is a new
program for C far and and actually truth
be told and they cover your ears this is
my favorite program at CFR but you know
cosmology and gravity's close second
it's a wonderful partnership with the
Israeli foundation which is how we got
into this business and really it's as
Alan told us earlier it's it's part of
our commitment to helping nurture the
next generation of research leaders and
for this program
the idea is to choose an international
cohort of exceptional early career
investigators who are looking for a
chance to think differently about
research so not only are they
exceptionally good in their own
disciplines of research but they're
interested in other disciplines of
research that's really what we're
looking for and so they will become the
next generation of research leaders I've
had the pleasure of seeing many of these
global scholars at our program meetings
because of course as Island said that's
one of the benefits they join a research
program and if you want to be
intimidated by very smart young people
you should meet them and talk to them
they're frightening ly intelligent and
good in addition to the three scholars
you'll hear from tonight I'd like to
point out there's a few locals Alan said
the global scholars are from 18 scholars
from five different countries so we
couldn't afford to bring them all
together tonight and they're all in fact
I met two of them in Vancouver at the
program meeting Alan referred to
yesterday but there are two here from
the University of Toronto and so we
should recognize them too Luo yiyang
there's Luo Yi she's in the quantum
materials program
and miko type allayed who's in molecular
architecture of light miko you hide in
various but now for the main event
they're both assistant professors here
at the university of toronto and off to
what will be fantastically successful
careers
now our first speaker tonight is
gabriela cohen dr. Sol Cohen is an
assistant professor in the Department of
Chemistry at the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology her research group uses
single molecule spectroscopy and
ultra-fast laser spectroscopy and don't
worry she's going to tell you what she
means but there'll be a test afterwards
you have to define what a femtosecond is
in the question and answer period these
tools state-of-the-art tools provide a
detailed molecular level picture of how
biological systems work and of course
she's in the bio-inspired solar energy
program so her group focuses on
investigating photosynthetic light
harvesting she's a recipient of a
Beckman Young Investigator award and the
Smith family award for excellence in
biomedical research please join me in
welcoming dr. Slava : thank you thanks
for that introduction
so tonight I'm gonna talk to you about
how the biggest problem facing our
society was solved three and a half
billion years ago by bacteria so the
biggest problem we're facing is climate
change the rise in co2 shown on these
plots and the associated climate impacts
are sending us on a path to destruction
and this means we need dramatic changes
in our energy usage and changes in our
energy sources when we think about
renewable energy sources solar energy is
a particularly attractive option and
that's because in just one hour of
sunlight there's more energy incident on
the Earth's surface from the Sun then is
consumed by humans over an entire year
and so when we're thinking about
technology for the next five maybe the
next ten years
silicon photovoltaics
like the pictures that we see here these
are the technology that we'll use but
when we want to think further than that
when we want to think 20 50 years down
the road what we want is a solar energy
technology that doesn't have the
limitations of silicon photovoltaics
specifically silicon photovoltaics don't
have high power density meaning they're
not good at capturing sunlight which is
relatively dilute and concentrating it
to a strong power source that we need to
drive our machinery also there's an
issue of reliability we can see that on
the picture of the Earth's surface there
are clouds and the more clouds the less
energy from your solar panels but these
problems have been solved
they've been solved by evolution so
photosynthetic systems like
photosynthetic like plants and
photosynthetic bacteria have solved
issues like reliability and so we want
to know can we understand how they work
and from that understanding pull out key
principles that will allow us to develop
the next generation of solar energy
sources so the major idea behind how
they solve this problem is the same idea
that we saw in the recent Star Wars
movie rogue one so it's the idea of an
antenna dish the climax of this movie
for those who haven't seen it was all
about this antenna dish that can
concentrate information and transmit
high information to high density
information to ships in space in this
case it was the plans for the Death Star
but photosynthetic systems they use the
same kind of concept where they have an
antenna to concentrate solar energy and
for photosynthetic systems this antenna
dish is actually dynamic
it's smaller under sunny day conditions
and it gets bigger under cloudy day
conditions so it depends on what the
environment is like now this is a key
difference between how biological
systems work and how most devices that
we manufacture work devices we
manufacture are usually manufactured to
a spec they perform to that spec maybe
degrade gradually biological systems are
dynamic they're constantly changing and
we're organizing in response to their
environment and so this is one place
where we see that kind of idea
work to their advantage so for
photosynthetic systems the antenna dish
is actually made of proteins so here's
our molecular model of what this antenna
dish looks like so it's similar for
plants here I'm showing you the version
for photosynthetic bacteria here's the
model of this protein Network we can
think about it using a simpler picture
and essentially what happens is there's
absorption of sunlight and then that
absorbed energy migrates through this
network to a central location where
electricity is generated so the
trajectory that I'm showing here this is
just one of many many possible
trajectories so sunlight that's absorbed
throughout this antenna dish is
concentrated to generate electricity at
high power densities we want to know how
does nanoscale organization of this
protein antenna drive this process which
is known as light harvesting we want to
know what are the properties of these
individual proteins and how are they
organized to create this functional
antenna dish so when we're thinking
about this the key idea is identifying
what are the timescales and mechanisms
behind this energy flow timescales is
the key parameter and identifying what
this
test looks like and it also gives us
insight into the mechanism or how it
works so this energy flow that I show
here is actually a series of energy
transfer steps so it's a series of
incredibly fast energy transfer steps
and we want to understand each one of
them but how do we do that how do we
look at something so fast will we do
that with ultra-fast lasers so this is a
picture of the ultra-fast laser system
in my lab at MIT and what ultra-fast
lasers do is they actually allow us to
look at a process that's a millionth of
a billionth of a second long
that's a femtosecond for those of you
who are taking notes for the tests that
john told you is gonna come later so how
our ever Attis works is we have two of
these laser pulses that hit our sample
the first one it's like the Sun it
excites it and then the second laser
pulse is like our camera so it checks in
to see what's going on and in this way
we're able to look at energy transfer
processes on this incredibly short
timescale and that's the technology that
we use to look at something so fast but
how do we zoom in inside a cell and look
at this energy transfer process inside a
bacteria well we do that by actually
building up piecewise this protein
network that forms the antenna dish so
in my lab we build it where we take a
membrane and we embed within it these
individual proteins in this way by
building it up piecewise we can actually
look at these two key ideas the
properties of the protein and the
properties of the organization and so in
one recent result we looked at energy
transfer in this kind of system and we
compared the energy transfer rates in
these isolated proteins and
found that certain important steps in
that energy flow are 30% faster in this
membrane environment and so what that
tells us is what surrounds the proteins
is an important knob that biological
systems can tune that allows them to
control this efficient light harvesting
and so this is one idea that we've
learned from photosynthesis about one
knob that allows us to get increased
power from light harvesting and that
kind of idea is something that can now
be applied to devices we can think about
ways we can concentrate sunlight using
similar knobs to increase the efficacy
of the solar cells but equally important
is then as we're improving the devices
going back to the fundamental science
thinking more deeply about how
photosynthesis works and the kind of
basic principles at play there so we can
continue to use fundamental science to
improve devices now this idea of
learning from nature is not new humanity
has always been inspired by nature we
saw birds and we built a plane that's
how I got here today but what's new is
we can now look down at the nanoscale
and with that new power we can use how
some of the world's tiniest organisms
work to solve our biggest problems thank
you
[Applause]
thank you very much Gabriela oh they've
got a pass over the controller here so
next we're gonna hear from Natalie bough
who is an assistant professor in the
Department of Economics here at the
University of Toronto her research
explores the interaction between
cultural norms economic behavior and
development policies
amongst other things her work examines
the role school building plays and
female educational achievements and how
changes in pension plans can affect
educational investments differently
depending on cultural norms her work
shows how policies can have unintended
consequences and underlines the
importance of understanding how
individual reactions to policies based
on cultural norms will affect how policy
initiatives will affect growth please
join me in welcoming dr. Bob
as you know my name is Natalie Bao and
today I'd like to tell you about the
economics of culture until recently both
economists and policymakers have
neglected the important role that
culture plays in determining the effects
of different world scale development
policies we believe that some
development policies like pension plan
expansions or school construction
programs are good and that they should
be implemented everywhere and pretty
much the same way however this is
starting to change in 2015 the World
Bank not typically the most radical
organization and I should know as a
former world bank employee will least an
annual development loophole called mine
society and behavior this will put high
weighted the importance of cultural
context for determining the effects of
different development policies it said
that policymaking should not be one size
fits all to show you that if we neglect
the important world a cultural place we
will get it wrong and will fail to
understand the effects of different
policies I'd like to talk to you about
two examples from my own walk well the
title of this slide the cultural causes
of everything might be a slight
overstatement
hopefully I least convince you that even
if cultural doesn't cause everything
it's still incredibly important first
I'll tell you about a cultural norm
called wide price and I'll show you that
this cultural norm with some goals to
benefit from world school construction
programs in Indonesia and Zambia while
opposed to no I'll then talk to you
about a novel set of cultural norms that
determine which children support parents
in the old age and I'll show you that
actually pension plans can have very
strong negative unintended consequences
in some cultural contexts actually
reducing education among some ethnic
groups in Indonesia and Ghana in both
cases we'll see that cultural context is
important for determining the effects of
different development policy
is unfamiliar since the education of
goals is important to both take goals
out of poverty and low-income countries
and also bring though families out of
poverty as this quotation by Hillary
Clinton illustrates understanding the
crucial effect of cultural context is
important for thinking about policies
that close gender gaps and help goals
succeed in school
so without further ado let me tell you
about wide place
why place is a cultural tradition where
the groom makes a payment to the parents
of the bride at the time of marriage in
many countries particularly in Africa
blyde places are traditionally paid in
cows
however today by prices are more
commonly paid in cash and in fact by
places are such a big part of the
cultural ethos that you can find bride
place calculators like this bride place
app from Nigeria here I've inputted my
details somewhat oval exaggerating my
cooking skills and I've discovered that
as a premium babe I won't applied price
of five hundred and fifty thousand well
this tradition might seem unfamiliar to
us it's actually quite common in much of
the world here I've put up a map that
I've stolen from F no Maps you see
countries in red our countries where
blind places traditionally the
predominate custom you can see there
much of sub-saharan Africa by places
very common and this is also the case in
parts of Indonesia even though black ice
is very widespread many activists view
errors or public tradition they think
that it's symbol to buying and selling
women and those even been calls to ban
wide place in Uganda and Kenya despite
these potential negative aspects of
blyde place norms why place also has an
interesting potentially positive aspect
it turns out that blyde place amounts
increase with female education this is
so well known that when we began woke on
blind place
we went to Osaka Zambia and we
interviewed wide price negotiators they
told us about this positive relationship
between black boys amounts and female
education and so this is a quote by a
bride price negotiator who tells us the
bride price amounts increase with female
education because an educated goal
brings value to her husband's family of
course we don't just have to take the
black boys negotiators world for this we
can also collect data implied price
amounts and match it to female education
and see if in fact blood fights amounts
do increase with female education
so here I've estimated the returns to
education for by place in Indonesia and
Zambia the y-axis here our in percents
and you can see that for go in Indonesia
moving from no education to attending
junior secondary school more than
doubles hope I place attending college
double supply place again and we see the
same strong positive relationship
between female education and blood place
in Zambia as in Indonesia so if white
boys amounts increase with education
it's possible that the blyde place
custom incentivizes parents to educate
their daughters to see if this is the
case along with my co-authors
nada a schwa David nun and Alessandro
Vina
I studied the effect of world scale
school construction programs in
Indonesia and Zambia in both countries
we found a striking result among ethnic
groups they had a tradition of paying
high blind places when access to schools
increased female education also
increased however among ethnic groups
that didn't have these high blood placed
traditions the school construction
program had no effect on female
education and so surprisingly if you
simply wanted to maximize female
education for the school construction
program you would want to build schools
and the aliens with a lot of ethnic
groups will traditionally highboy places
so what does this teach us well for
school
was crucial for the design of obscure
policies and also for the evaluation of
world scale policies because he'll the
school construction program had very
different effects depending on different
groups ethnic norms
additionally banning a cultural norm
like glide place despite its potential
negative effects could have a downside
it could reduce female education and
therefore if we want a ban by place we
might want to also subsidize female
education and finally even though
cultural context is crucial for
designing policy we can still warm from
one country to think about policy in a
very different country here we can learn
lessons from Muslim Indonesia for
predominantly Christian Zambia okay
so cultural notes don't just interact
with different policies they can also
have negative unintended consequences to
show you how this can happen let me tell
you about a novel piece of my research
focusing on the cultural norms of match
locality and patch locality in my
research I hypothesized the match
locality incentivizes parents to educate
their daughters this is because dawdles
take care of the parents in the old age
and therefore educating a daughter was
way for parents to save for retirement
similarly I had prophesized that patch
locality incentivizes parents in
low-income countries to educate their
sons it turns out that this is exactly
the case if we walk across countries in
countries who are higher percentage of
citizens while traditionally patchy
local those module gender gaps in
education between men and woman in fact
patch vocality explains about 5% of the
global gender gap so what happens when
you Institute a pension plan which gives
parents an alternative way of saving
instead of educating their children well
it turns out that these pension plans
can actually reduce education in
Indonesia when you introduce a pension
matcha local dawdles finish less
schooling and in Ghana when you
introduce a pension plan patch local
sons also finish West schooling now
clearly this was not the intention of
the designers of the pension plans they
had just hoped to increase welfare they
could have never imagined that the
cultural context in Indonesia would will
lead them to reduce female education
among some ethnic groups so yet again we
see that cultural is crucial for
crafting successful policies and that
policymaking should not be
one-size-fits-all
in fact even the most well intentioned
policies can have negative unintended
consequences when we fail to consider
the cultural context however economics
can offer us who have tools to try and
understand how cultural norms want to
act with different policies and try and
predict how the effects of policies in
new contexts so a growing group of liesl
tools are now thinking about and
generally knowledge about the
interactions between different cultural
norms and policies it's our hope that
eventually this results will influence
the actions of different development
agencies like my former employer the
World Bank if you'd like to warm out or
about my research I put up my email
address here for you I'm looking forward
to hearing your calm
various features his Graham Taylor now
Graham is an assistant professor in the
School of Engineering at the University
of Guelph where he leads the machine
learning research group and I'm sure by
now all of you have read about machine
learning the next big thing in
artificial intelligence his research
focuses on statistical machine learning
with an emphasis on deep learning and
sequential data much of his work has
focused on seeing people in images and
video he has received recently a very
competitive Canada France strategic
partnership grant and he's also the
academic director of next AI a
non-profit initiative to establish
Canada as the AI hub for research
venture creation and technology
commercialization and now join me in
welcoming dr. Taylor
[Applause]
one Saturday morning I set off with my
two-year-old son Glenn to the Halton
County rail museum which is about 20
minutes from Guelph so I got out my
phone pulled up Google Maps entered our
destination into it and we set off and
about a minute into our drive my phone
started talking to me it said that our
destination would be closed by the time
we got there and so we headed back now
this is very simple but it was actually
for me as an AI researcher a
life-changing moment I realize how much
AI was embedded into my life today I'm
going to take you through a cascade of
changes from a navigation app to an
itinerary planner to self-driving cars
and finally to virtual reality
experiences generated by AI where you
don't even need to leave your house I'm
gonna talk about what happens when AI
moves from prediction to creation now of
course this might conjure up terrifying
images of Hal 9000 from 2001 or Skynet
from the Terminator series and of course
in popular culture this is a legitimate
concern but my goal for you is to become
an informed contributor to the dialogue
on how we might interact with a world of
smart machines but first let me take you
into my lab and tell you a little bit
about what we do that's not my lab this
is my life
so we focus on three elements all of
which are connected by deep learning
algorithms applications and acceleration
so first let's talk about algorithms and
architectures machine learning is all
about transforming inputs which come in
the form of data to useful outputs like
predictions visualizations and decisions
I tend to like to think of it as a
computer program so I could write a
computer program to square a number and
I could write a computer program to read
in a series of chords and output a
melody
[Music]
but some computer programs are really
really tough for humans to write just
think about writing a program to drive a
car even if you are a spectacular
programmer that would be very difficult
to do and the best way to write such a
program is to learn from experience
that's the amazing thing about machine
learning we can learn these really
complicated programs without any human
program when programmer in the loop all
we need is data and architecture and a
learning algorithm so let's talk about
architectures architectures are the
mapping from input to output and deep
learning an area that has emerged with
Canada as leader in part due to see if
our support is all about inspiration
from the brain defining multiple layers
of representation to go from input to
output
but architecture is alone is not enough
these structures have tens or hundreds
of millions of parameters that must be
fit some way and this is the automatic
probic programming that takes place so
the way this happens is typically
through the use of pairs of inputs and
outputs and a trial and error process
where the predictions are gradually
driven towards better and better
solutions and there's no single best
learning learning algorithm or
architecture for now it's largely the
result of human ingenuity but it will be
a major inflection point when machines
learn how to learn second we have
applications and my group tends to focus
on something called computer vision
which is about teaching computers to see
just like humans because people are the
dominant subject in nearly all images
and videos we tend to have our vision
centred on them and this leads to
applications like person detection
identification activity recognition and
emotion recognition however being at the
University of Guelph Canada's food
University has allowed us to apply
computer vision to challenging problems
in agri-food so I've worked with
collaborators in plant agriculture and
environmental science to generate smart
traps that can automatically detect
insect pests that are destroying
orchards and also build drone solutions
that can monitor cover crops that
restore nitrogen to soil I'd like to
mention that I'd like to also to
envision a drone flying across the stage
we had brought one here today and after
we crashed it two times during rehearsal
they told us no way no drones in this
room so just use your imagination so in
an era of increased population and
climate change we're working together
with twelfths food institutes to work
towards machine learning algorithms that
can assist a sustainable growth
production and consumption of food now
the third and final a is acceleration
machine learning is computationally
intensive and that's why we're actively
working towards systems that can learn
faster and with reduced power part of
deep learning success is a result of
these things here called graphics
processing units these are specialized
computer architectures that have
thousands of course and the interesting
thing is that they were repurposed from
hardcore gamers they have been the
dominant mode of computation for the
last ten years while machine learning
has largely existed in the cloud and
you've probably interacted with these
systems on a daily basis when you do an
internet search or you receive an Amazon
or Netflix recommendation or you use
face recognition in the Photos app but
there's always been a gap there's the
internet between you and the system in
other words you've never really met the
but as machine learning moves from the
cloud to the physical world the
computational demands won't diminish but
power consumption must so the drone that
flies over the field and not only
detects weeds but takes action on them
or the human a humanoid robot in your
home that's folding your laundry and
unloading your dishwasher they're not
going to be so useful if they constantly
need to recharge and that's why our
group is working on ways to develop
learning algorithms that can run at ten
to a hundred times less power on
specialized architectures now the
systems I've talked about so far are
largely prediction machines they produce
simple outputs but the world is moving
towards machines that create art music
dialogue pros a central problem with
predictive machines and creative sorry
creative machines is that machine
learning requires an objective function
and this is typically based on
minimizing error for these simple
predictive systems minimizing errors
pretty simple you just try to match the
prediction against some desired output
but when it comes to machines that
create how are we supposed to measure
the quality of their outputs a major
problem here is the fact that there's
often no single right answer I'd like to
draw your attention here to something
called Google inbox I receive about a
hundred emails a day and this AI based
application will read my emails suggests
three replies and I can simply click on
a button
it's really quite amazing and I am a bit
embarrassed to say it but I use it for
about five percent of my emails and as I
use it it will continue to get better so
this kind of human-in-the-loop style
AI is where I see us as humans
coexisting with machines for quite some
time
it makes the creation and I perform the
judgment another problem with these
creative machines is the fact that their
output is very structured it's very
complex so if you take something simple
like again visual recognition I show an
image to an algorithm I ask it what is
that image this is just a standard
computer vision recognition problem the
output is just a category but if I ask
an AI to make me a meal suddenly the
output is much more structured and
complex and this is just talking about
getting the recipe straight if the
machines actually working on taking
physical action in the world this gets
much much more complicated so in
conclusion the early stages of creative
machines have actually resulted in
auto-generated art poetry and music
so this is actually an AI generated team
and it's kind of catchy so when I talk
about Google inbox or mains machine
translation systems or even chat BOTS
these are actually applications that are
driving significant industrial value but
I actually think the potential of
creative machines has not been fully
realized and this is in part by them
being locked inside the cloud so where
you come in is in defining what we want
from creative machines at least for now
we're still the architects of these
systems and we have the power to drive
their development so if you have any
ideas I'd love to hear them just send me
an email and I promise to respond
personally embarrass you by making you
answer questions we can do this a lot of
two ways I can ask the questions if you
want to ask questions you have to ask
only one short one and we'll make sure
that each one of the three panels gets a
question so which way do you want to do
it okay question pretending the
politicians aren't here
I would ask Natalie does she see any
current government incentives that
perhaps could be put through the filter
she's suggesting for better and more
effective outcomes okay well a cup
question so I'm actually quite new to
Canada but I think I can say a little
bit about how I think governments can
take cultural context into account when
they do the walk and I think I have a
few policy recommendations for
governments of course the first thing is
to simply just think about the cultural
context of where you're doing your walk
and that might include going down and
talking to people and doing focus groups
but another thing that can be very
helpful because people may not even know
how the culture might affect those
two different policies is the induced
policy experiments in different places
so you could imagine rolling out
policies in a way that we can actually
test the effects of different policies
so randomly varying different parts of
policies estimating the effects in
different places or randomizing the time
and when we roll out policies so we can
actually get a sense of how a policy is
walking and not just how talking on
average but how it's working for
different types of people good I'm gonna
turn to Gabriella and say based on my
deep level of ignorance of
photosynthesis I understand it's not
that efficient but it does generate sure
generates an energy source that we can
store getting around the storage problem
for electricity so double-barreled
question how far do you think we are
away from beating photosynthesis at
efficiency in making a real fuel rather
than just electricity so I think there
are two approaches that we could take to
beating photosynthesis to make fuel one
is the entirely materials way create
kind of light harvesting I was talking
about add a catalyst to it and then the
other is improving on photosynthesis
creating improved algae that can do a
much better job than current
photosynthesis so I would say kind of
surprisingly we're actually closer in
this one then in this one here so in
terms of but I okay I will preface that
by saying I think climate change is a
big enough issue that we need to move
forward on all fronts as fast as
possible so we can't wait till we fail
in one direction before exploring
another okay so does anybody want to ask
the scary robot question
go ahead some of the economists and
business professors that you know while
at the Rotman School been thinking a lot
about the economic implications of
artificial intelligence and and they
characterize AI is dramatically dropping
the cost of prediction and you know you
can you can think about it you know
there's obvious things you could predict
but if you think about sort of creation
one way to think about it is more AI
could predict what music people would
like or what art they would like to to
observe I mean is that is that a way to
sort of try to put put creation in AI I
actually don't see it as as I mean use a
technical term binary I actually see it
as a continuum from prediction to
creation the specific example that you
gave of I'm gonna use the word
prediction here predicting what kind of
music or art someone would like I would
still cast that towards the end of the
spectrum at the prediction that because
of because the the output itself is
still could be enumerated it's it's low
dimensional it's a it's a choice so that
and those types of services are ones
that we're consuming right now so I was
trying to point towards maybe what's on
what's on the horizon but I think these
recommend we call them recommendation
systems they're getting better I'm using
them all the time many of us are using
them and they exist I wouldn't go as far
as to call them creation when I say
creation I actually mean the the system
generates something high dimensional
like like text or an image or if I
showed you some examples of poetry and
so forth it's a continuum so it's if you
don't like the word creation what we
make some another technical term for it
a structured prediction emphasis
emphasis on the complexity of the output
and the fact that it's highly
interrelated and and correlated as
opposed to just a single scalar out
at ten past nine I was to draw this to a
close so I think our host has final
remarks if I'm not mistaken
but I think we should start by thanking
the three global scholars who've shown
us just how wonderful well I hope
everyone's enjoyed their evening I'm
barb stylist and I have the great honor
of chairing this amazing board of this
amazing institution it's been a great
evening for all of us to have a window
on how some global scholars are thinking
about some of the world's most important
issues I think the complexity of solving
economic issues is well illustrated by
an Iommi's discussion around culture I
think that you can't pick up a newspaper
or a magazine without understanding or
without certainly reading something
about AI and how its evolving in every
discussion we have we learn a little bit
more so today I learned about the
difference between prediction and and
creation and I think that was that was
excellent and then of course one of the
the problems that I think we all worry
about leaving the world in better shape
for our children and understanding how
how we could learn from nature to solve
our sustainability issues was fantastic
to to really understand the work that's
being done in the photosynthesis area so
thank you to Gabriela and thank you to
Natalie and and thank you to Graham and
amazing insights into everything you're
doing thank you to the Israeli
foundation for working as a great
partner with us in funding our global
scholars I think it's absolutely
imperative for Canada to build its
capacity
and it's great that Canada can fund and
and lead in developing global scholars
so not just Canadians but it was also
great to to have someone from the
southern so the south side of the border
I think you all know how we work at CFR
I think many of you are veterans of our
CFR events it's always fantastic to
expand our brains and understand what's
going on in the scientific community and
as Alan and I often discuss really being
at the Nexus of understanding that the
advancements in science and how advances
in science can change the world for the
better is what makes being a part of the
CFR families so exciting so I just
wanted to end by thanking all of you for
coming and a very special thank you to
our two ministers who are here Minister
Duncan and Minister Moretti great honor
that you could join us today and of
course our our left hanok governor great
to see you again and thank you for your
support of CFR enjoy your evening and
see you next time at our next CFR event
thanks so much
you
[Music]